[Music]
fifty years ago on the 20th of April
1968 Enoch Powell the Tory shadow
defense secretary made a speech in
Berlin in 15 or 20 years on present
trends there will be in this country
three and a half million come
Commonwealth immigrants and their
descendants it was destined to become
the most infamous speech made by any
British politician since the war as I
look ahead
I am fitted with much foreboding like
the Roman I seem to see the white river
Tiber forming with much blood in it he
warned that the character of the British
nation was under threat from mass
Commonwealth immigration in this country
in 12 or 20 years time the black man
will have the whip hand over the white
man this is the story of Enoch Powell of
his rivers of blood and how he changed
British politics
[Music]
by the late 1960s hundreds of thousands
of Commonwealth citizens had made their
home in Britain including the Jaspers
who hailed from India but settled in
Wolverhampton this is the first passport
my mum
oh wow when she came it's see we've kept
it oh how old is she there Susie's about
35 36 there and so when did they come
over she week actually became in 1965 it
was exactly these sorts of families whom
Powell had in mind when he rose to speak
it was electric the first time a major
politician had spoken out against the
establishment consensus on immigration
which had held between both parties
since the war and he did so in a way
designed to shock he would he told a
friend send a firework and light up the
sky milk kinder grew up to be mayor of
Wolverhampton and remembers the impact
of speech had on his community this is
the street when the speech boy in
apparel was made this is where we
actually lived you and your family yes
your parents and the community at the
time what did they make of it they were
petrified terrified they were very
nervous they were very worried because
the implication was that immigrants need
to go back home that we would be thrown
out of the country the impact it had was
that my mother never ever changed her
nationality because of that speech what
why because she thought she would be
thrown out because she was supposed to
go home yes and this is the house where
we actually lived when the speech was
made much of the speech doesn't exist on
tape but it wasn't surprising that mal
Kinder's mother was scared
Powell was saying not only the
immigration should cease but that
everything should be done to encourage
her and her family to leave and if she
didn't the character of Britain itself
as a nation would be lost
[Music]
it split the country down the middle
[Music]
but Powell was right that his
constituents the white working-class
were largely behind him
[Music]
reporters of smithfield marched in
protest in support of he knocked out
dangerous it was populist it was playing
to the worst sentiments which were then
quite widespread they thought this was
visionary this was long overdue
rescission it should be implemented we
should this was the new Messiah I
remember saying to my agent of time if
Enoch Powell stood for leadership of the
Conservative Party today he would sweep
the board we shall be destroyed other
phrases in that speech which really are
unwise unpleasant absolutely calculated
to excite someone who did have racialist
feelings
[Music]
allies of Powell say this was never
about racism numbers the share of wait
of immigrants that were settling in
certain areas was going to cause
difficult social relations and Paul had
been a soldier in India in the Second
World War he left just before partition
and he had seen the beginnings of
communal violence between Muslims and
Hindus in India and I think he was
incredibly concerned it might happen
here this speech was delivered just over
a fortnight after Martin Luther King's
assassination and America was being torn
apart by racial riots but for its
critics this wasn't about America or
India it was about the law closer to
home it was time to try and make the
Conservative Party take a opposition
stance against legislation which made it
illegal to discriminate on grounds of
color class or creed this was not about
immigrants it was about what happens to
people here we had small employment
agency where people had to fill in a
form time and again we get scrolled
across these forms the word no colors
Paul said that he wasn't speaking on
behalf of himself but on behalf of his
constituents of this place of
Wolverhampton because he argued that
their concerns weren't being listened to
that they were being suppressed by a
powerful group of elites a group of
people who are trying to steal his
constituents country away from them
sound familiar
well it should because Enoch Powell was
the first British modern populist he was
the Midwife of the politics of identity
and a betrayal
50 years on power light questions of
identity politics sovereignty and
nationalism cast a long shadow I think
we live in the age of power I think if
you take that speech in 1968 and you
strip away the clip type of academic
times and you strip away the classical
illusions and the rhetorical flourishes
what you have is the manifesto for
modern populism
it's the idea that's speaking out
against immigration is the act of a
courageous and visionary statesman it's
the idea that what immigrants want is
not a quality it is domination what they
want is the whip hands over the local
population it's the idea that what
liberalism is about is about giving crow
villages and preferences to minority
groups and that has been the platform of
populist politics ever since in a way
our politics runs straight through
powers rivers of blood his arguments
against the EU elites and nationhood
have become mainstream and there are
many in places like the black country on
whose behalf he spoke then for whom he
still speaks now well I was brought up
in Wolverhampton in the area that he
used to represent so I was brought up
with that name every not being
constantly mentioned to me all the time
he's a hero I think to too many people
not just white working-class people from
me for sure
yes I have no question about it yeah I
think that he would do he would do
extremely well their children unable to
obtain school places their homes and
neighborhoods change beyond recognition
their plans and prospects for the future
change beyond recognition because of
immigration okay what do you think
sounds right on the money
totally wrong yeah absolutely because
there's there's no room for anybody
because of immigration obviously they've
come over took a lot of schools up took
a lot of housing benefits up and there's
no room for us English residents and our
and our children and
did you know about you don't pound yeah
he's great okay I'll think what he said
would happen so when he say yes what do
you put into what he in 15 or 20 years
time on the other side of ball bouncing
at West Park primary there's a very
different vision of Britain upon sure
this school criticized by Powell in the
60s as a place with almost no white
children is rehearsing a play which
tells both his and their stories and
which rejects his checkered legacy they
know what racism is they know it's ugly
they know it's important to speak out
against it this is a thriving community
with so many positive things to say
about itself that it that it thrives off
the energy that you can get from
diversity in the way he's shot himself
in the foot by saying what she said
because I think it's only motivated a
lot of people in this community to prove
him wrong it doesn't matter where you go
in the world you'll find white black
Asian it doesn't matter where you work
where you while you find people
different skin colors he's wrong to be
racist because everyone has the right to
be treated equally and he makes me feel
very uncomfortable hearing it he
impacted too many people's life and make
so much people go from this country
unmoved to someone else
all political careers end in failure
Powell once famously observed and it
never seemed truer than for his own life
but he believed he would be vindicated
by history regret that you're going to
be predominately remembered for this
speech when one looks at your other
political achievement I think I shall
also be remembered as an opponent of
Britain's membership of the European
community and when that has finally
collapsed I think my name will be on the
roll
Pawel died in 1998 he's buried here in
Warwick in the Church of his wartime
regiments Palmers any standards Enoch
Powell was a racist he was a sexist we
would have no compunction today in
calling him a bigot but what he will
also was well you can also say about
Enoch Powell is that he was a patriot
it's the reason he's buried here under
these colors but a patriot - what - an
idea of Britain - a type of Britain but
even by his own time was already
slipping away
Powell was a man of enormous
intellectual gifts yet he was oblivious
to the ironies of that which he
bequeathed us he had wanted a debate on
immigration but for years debate was
stifled by a speech he made he feared
the division of a nation yet who or what
was Britain divided by more than Enoch
Powell himself